quand j'étais au lycée j'étais
adolescent il n'y avait pas que
intéressé dans la vie j'avais pas vrai
r mai
qui m'intéressait c'était de m'amuser
avec mes amis et c'était à peu près tout
ce qu'il avait envie de faire en vrai de
vrai et de
ce fait là quand je me retrouve avec mes
amis je me rendais compte que le truc
qui m'intéressait le plus et où je
m'amuse le plus lorsque j'étais avec eux
c'était quand on écoutait de la musique
et que tout le monde s'amusait et tout
le monde était réuni autour de semaine
cette même un peu passion qu'on avait
c'était la musique et
de là je me suis dit que j'avais envie
d'être un peu plus que simples auditeurs
et j'avais envie de passer du côté
composition et sans même aller même
juste dans cette réflexion là j'avais
envie de j'avais envie de m'intéresser à
ça de ce fait j'ai directement
était sur l'ordinateur de ma mère et
j'ai téléchargé un logiciel s'appelle
effet le studio et c'est un logiciel de
composition musicale
qui a adapté à la fois pour les
débutants mais aussi pour les
professionnels
et lorsque je suis arrivé sur ce
logiciel j'ai vu en premier qu'il
fallait cet homme un tempo donc un bébé
m
alors là bas du coup j'étais un peu je
savais pas trop quoi faire parce que moi
je sais même pas ce que à quoi ça
servait je savais pas même quelle était
l'utilité d'un bpm dans le morceau
qu'est ce qu'il fallait que je mette
comme comme nombre
du coup j'ai simplement été voir le
tempo des morceaux que qui nous amuser
le plus sont en tout cas qui faisait le
plus d'effet à mes amis à moi même quand
on était en soirée ou quand on était
dans le bus ou n'importe où et que l'on
faisait un peu n'importe quoi parce que
le but de mes compositions à la base en
fait c'était juste d'amuser mes amis
donc du coup je me suis calquer par
imitation sur les tempos que
que les même tempo que les morceaux que
j'écoutais que ce soit des morceaux
américains ou des morceaux français et
je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait plus
bpm été élevé en tout cas j'avais
l'impression que plus bpm était élevé
plus mes amis danser sur les
compositions que j'aurais écouté avait
envie 2e même chanter et c'est donc je
trouvais ça intéressant je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait un lien quand même
du coup entre mon environnement et la
musique que j'allais produire parce que
forcément j'étais directement influencée
par ce fait là de voir ce devoir
d'amuser mes amis quoi et puis après ben
mon environnement il a vachement changé
parce que je suis descendu dans le sud
de la france j'ai changé d'école j'ai
changer d'amis je les voyais moins et
plus du coût baisse et une perte de ma
vie où je me suis senti un petit peu
plus seul c'est la première fois que je
ressentais un peu de la solitude et
j'étais dans une école qui me plaisait
pas trop
j'aimais pas les courges et mais pas
trop et la population non plus du coup
mais je suis plus rester chez moi et à
ce moment là je faisais je faisais pas
mal de composition et je me suis rendu
compte un peu inconsciemment que les
tempos de mes compositions que
j'utilisais ont commencé à baisser au
fur et à mesure que que je progressais
dans mon année est donc un peu dans mon
malheur
est en fait je me suis rendu compte que
tout simplement mes émotions changer
parce que je me sentais moins bien et
les tempos bah du coup il baissait
progressivement et j'avais plus envie de
faire des compositions mélancoliques
avec
moins de percussion des rythme plus lent
quelque chose de moins effréné qu'avant
en fait parce que ben ce que je vivais
ça avait changé j'étais plus du tout
dans le même environnement et dans la
même dynamique
du coup là j'ai compris un truc à ce
moment là qu'ils étaient quand même je
pense à un premier step dans
mon bain construction musicale c'est que
il ya un lien direct en fait entre les
émotions et les tempos que je vais
choisir et donc à quoi va ressembler ma
musique donc j'ai trouvé ça quand même
assez intéressant et le temps a passé et
puis donc j'ai évidemment quitter cette
école que j'aimais pas du tout et
j'ai commencé à travailler de plus en
plus sur ma musique et lorsque j'ai
signé en maison dit je me suis dit bon
bah c'est peut-être le moment de c'est
peut-être le moment de me lancer à fond
dedans et j'ai commencé à beaucoup
travailler avec les artistes au studio
chose que je ne faisais pas avant je
travaillais dans ma chambre et donc du
coup je me suis rendu compte que à ce
moment là le travail il est complètement
différent il devient beaucoup plus
collaboratif et c'est surtout la science
de l'instant qui compte est de savoir
agir au studio
directement ça veut dire que c'est plus
forcément la technique qui compte les
meilleures mélodies la meilleure
connaissance musicale c'est surtout
arriver à se connecter avec l'artiste en
fait arriver à comprendre là où il veut
aller et à le mettre en adéquation avec
ce que nous en tant que compositeur on a
dans la tête
de 7 là j'ai compris assez vite qu'il y
avait deux options au studio pour
déterminer un peu le tempo et donc
l'univers du morceau qui va en découler
le premier c'est que l'artiste en
question avec qui je suis au studio pour
travailler
prennent le lead en fait tout simplement
et me disent bon bah voilà aujourd'hui
je me sens comme ça j'ai envie de faire
tel type de morceaux ou bien plus
concrètement sur mon album j'ai telle
couleur j'ai besoin maintenant que tu
m'apportes cette couleur-là donc à
partir de ce moment là moi je les
utilise et de mon expérience de ma
connaissance de la musique pour pouvoir
adapter mon tempo et adapté ensuite
toute la construction du morceau qui va
s'ensuivre
mais il ya aussi une autre option c'est
que générallement ça repose un peu plus
sur la confiance qu'on a entre entre
autre compositeur et artiste mais la
deuxième option c'est plus que moi
justement à travers ce que moi j'ai
écouté de ces artistes là eh bien je lui
propose quelque chose en fait je lui
propose quelque chose de différent que
ce soit un tempo il n'a pas forcément
l'habitude de s'essayer que ce soit un
univers mélodique également différent et
moi je trouve que c'est eux c'est la
plus intéressant parce que c'est là on
arrive généralement à sortir l'artiste
de sa zone de confort sortir artistes
des sentiers battus et de ce qu'il a
déjà dit ce qu'il a déjà pu proposer ou
en tout cas de la wii sans forcément le
plus à l'aise
donc c'est là que j'ai compris une
deuxième chose je pense assez importante
dans mon métier ce qui était devenu en
tout cas mon métier depuis c'est que
mon métier c'était plus seulement de
composer mais c'est au studio en fait de
pouvoir
déjà identifié une émotion de départ ou
en tout cas une idée que ce soit dans la
tête de l'artiste ou bien dans la mienne
et deux à l'aide de mon ordinateur et de
tous les outils que j'ai à ma
disposition
l'amplifier est arrivé en faire un
morceau construit qui nous plaisent et
qui soit écoutable par les autres parce
que généralement lorsque je fais de la
musique c'est de la musique est destiné
à sortir et donc à être écouté par le
public et et qu'ils puissent lui plaire
tout simplement
j'ai un exemple un peu pour qu'ils me
virent en tête là pour étayer un peu ce
que je dis par exemple j'étais au sud
avec avec un artiste en travailler sur
son album c'est un assez gros artistes
donc c'était son des morceaux qui sont
assez importants parce qu'ils peuvent
générer beaucoup de beaucoup d'écouté
donc beaucoup d'argent et donc on était
plusieurs compositeurs avec ces artistes
là on a créé un morceau la session était
là session nos studios été assez longue
on a passé beaucoup de temps sur le
morceau et plus vu que on sentait tout
ce que c'était un bon morceau tout le
monde voulait rajouter de sa patte on
avait tous une idée rajoute des
percussions ici rajouter une mélodie
encore une harmonie si peu alors là on
va on va changer complètement va faire
autre chose et donc à la fin le morceau
on le trouvait tout c'est incroyable on
est tous rentrés chez nous et puis le
lendemain lorsque ça me revenus tous au
studio on s'est rendu compte qu'en fait
c'était un peu pas inaudible mais qu'en
fait ça partait dans tous les sens et
donc au fur et à mesure on a commencé à
enlever un petit peu de cette percussion
là qu'on avait rajouté à 3 heures du
matin dans l'euphorie de la session
studio enlever cette mélodie qui était
peut-être un peu trop au final et en
fait on est arrivé à un piano voix donc
il n'y avait plus aucune percussion
avait plus rien donc on pourrait se dire
que c'est là où il ya le moins de rythme
mais pourtant c'est à ce jour le morceau
qu'on préfère du projet et qui nous
touche le plus
donc le tempo c'est important il faut le
maîtriser
et
il ya aussi un autre truc c'est que vous
ne maîtrisez sauf que
c'est une donnée qui est inchangeable en
fait comme toutes les lois qui ont été
créés par l'univers c'est un change à
bhl et 120 bpm ça restera toujours 120
battements par minute donc je pense
qu'en fait maîtriser le tempo c'est pas
forcément ça qu'il faut je pense que
c'est plus maîtriser le notre rythme et
le rythme qu'on va utiliser ce qu'on a
dans la tête qui est important en soi on
n'est pas maître du tempo par contre les
maîtres de ce qu'on fait de ce qu'on a
dans la tête et c'est ça qu'il faut
cultiver je pense donc tout le jeu c'est
de trouver des rythmes originaux dans
différents tempos et qui s'intercale
bien c'est ça qui est important et ça
c'est pas forcément qu'avec les
percussions qu'on trouve ça c'est aussi
dans les mélodies c'est aussi dans la
rythmique de la voix et tout cela en
fait va créer un rythme qui va être
satisfaisant à notre oreille à celle des
autres
et
aussi je disais qu'au début je trouvais
que les rythmes rapides étaient ceux qui
qui nous amuse le plus avec mes amis etc
et c'est aussi quelque chose qui sait
c'est qu'un concert les musiques qui
sont entre 120 et 140 bpm serait
apparemment celle qui
serait le plus euphorique pour l'épauler
pour les auditeurs et leur permettrait
de deux d'avoir le plus de se procurer
le plus de plaisir en écoutant la
musique je ne connais pas vraiment la
véracité de cette information là mais en
tout cas il ya pas longtemps j'ai été
avec un autre ami à moi qui ai lu et
chanteur et il s'apprêtait à donner sa
première scène donc c'était une occasion
pour lui de voir comment son public et
les gens qui étaient venus le voir ses
auditeurs allaient réagir et à les
apprécier ou pas son concert et il avait
un petit peu peur parce que généralement
moi je travaille à la base dans le rap
et dans les concerts de rap est pas sans
savoir qu'il ya souvent pas mal
d'énergie et que c'est souvent
assez dynamique
et lui le truc c'est que il fait des
morceaux qui sont souvent assez doux où
justement le tempo est assez lent et
donc du coup c'est plus des morceaux
qu'on va écouter nous on va dire dans
nos écouteurs etc et ils avaient peur
que sur scène ça n'est pas vraiment un
effet de frénésie comme généralement on
attends
moi je savais pas vraiment quoi lui dire
parce que j'en savais pas beaucoup plus
que lui je lui dis bon bah tu verra bien
et lorsqu'il est monté sur scène des
premiers morceaux on a vu que c'était
complètement la furie dans la salle tout
le monde chantait les paroles tout le
monde danse et tout le monde se sauter
dessus lancé des bouteilles d'eau et c
est à ce moment là en fait je me suis
rendu compte d'un truc simple je me suis
rendu compte que ces gens là qui étaient
venus pour voir mon ami il n'était pas
venu pour écouter un tempo précise
n'était pas venu pour écouter
cette petite caisse claire qui était
intercalé entre ce petit rythme de piano
etc ils étaient juste venus voir
l'artiste en fait ils étaient juste
venus voir
les morceaux qu'ils écoutent au
quotidien qui leur procure des bonnes
émotions qui leur rappellent peut-être à
un moment de leur vie qui leur
rappellent peut-être je ne sais pas
quelque chose qui leur arrivait et je me
suis donc
rendu compte qu'en fait bas l'important
ce n'est pas de chercher le tempo
parfait parce que déjà moi je suis plus
tout sûr qu'il y en ait pas vraiment
parce qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de règle
dans la musique ce serait pas très
marrant il y en avait mais je pense que
le but c'est juste de trouver des
rythmes qui nous représente qui forment
notre identité je pense que c'est ça le
but de la musique s'est trouvé son
identité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]